[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to open
the conversation today
with the 14th Amendment.
150 years ago, 14th
Amendment was passed.
And we are in a juncture
that some people
are asking, how relevant is
14th Amendment to our situation
today?
So I wanted to ask
you, how far have
we come since the 14th Amendment
then to [? effect ?] and what
else--
how much do we have to go?
How many areas do we
need to invest and then
push for progress?
ABDI SOLTANI: Great.
Well, thank you so much
for having me here--
and for the people in
the room and anyone who's
watching the live stream
or listening to this later.
You know, the Constitution
of the United States
is one of the most
powerful legal documents,
one of the most durable.
It has qualities
that make it last.
But it also has the
ability to change.
And the way that the
Constitution changes--
you know, one is through
the formal amendments.
But it's also in the
way that the people
embrace the Constitution--
whether we defend it,
whether we stand for it, whether
we apply its principles fully,
or whether we step back from
it and let it be taken from us
or used against people's rights.
So the original Constitution
of the United States
basically created the separation
of powers between the Executive
Branch, Congress, the
Judiciary, and then
the basic structure of
federalism with the states.
But the Constitution originally
had very few protections
for individual
rights, and those were
enacted through the
first 10 Amendments
to the Constitution, which
we call the Bill of Rights.
So when you think about the
Constitutional amendments,
I think the Second Amendment
is obviously very famous.
It's always in the news.
People can associate
the Second Amendment
with whether it's collective
or an individual right
to bear arms.
The First Amendment also gets
a certain amount of attention,
and rightly so.
When people ask me what's
my favorite Amendment
of the Constitution,
though, my answer
is the 14th Amendment
of the Constitution.
The 14th Amendment
does a few things.
First, it says that all
persons born or naturalized
in the United States and
subject to the jurisdiction
thereof are citizens of the
United States and of the state
wherein they reside.
That's a profoundly
important sentence.
What it says is that there's
two paths to citizenship--
citizenship by birth
and citizenship
through the naturalization
or immigration process.
The reason the 14th Amendment
is my favorite amendment
is that I am a
citizen because of it.
I was born in this country--
when my parents are
both from Iran--
I was born in this
country in 1973.
And that's what
made me a citizen.
Because of the fact that
my parents were Iranians,
I associate my citizenship very
squarely with this Amendment
of the Constitution.
But every one of us who is a
citizen, every last person who
is a citizen, it's
either by birth
or through naturalization.
So the 14th Amendment,
that's one core plank.
After that, it goes on
to say that no state can
deny the privileges or
immunities of a citizen
of the United States.
And then, from there
it goes on, and it
changes from talking
about citizen to person.
And it says that no state can
deny to any person due process
under the law.
And that no state can
deny to any person
the equal protection of the law.
So the people who wrote
the 14th Amendment
did so in the aftermath
of abolishing slavery
in the United States.
The 13th Amendment that
immediately precedes the 14th
abolished slavery.
And at that time, the
thought was, well,
if you abolished slavery,
well, then, by definition,
the people who are
freed from slavery
should be treated equally as
human beings and as citizens.
But immediately, the states
that had slavery, as well
as the northern states,
set about a set of policies
to discriminate against
free black people.
And so the 14th Amendment
was necessary to make clear
that every person born here is a
citizen, that no state can take
away the rights of a citizen.
But then they switched from
talking only about citizens
to also talking
about persons, when
they said that every
person is entitled
to due process and
equal protection.
So why would they,
in crafting Section I
of the 14th Amendment, talk
about citizens and persons
so clearly?
It's because they
wanted the Constitution
to be abundantly clear--
that it applies on
the fundamental rights
of due process and equality
to every person, citizen
and non-citizen alike.
So I love the 14th Amendment.
I love it because it was the
path to my own citizenship,
but also because it marks
this country's progress
in the abolition of slavery
and the extension of rights
to every citizen
and to every person.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome, thanks.
And I think, from
this, we can probably
go to the question that
is in many people's minds
these days--
equal protection
for all persons.
I want to move to
the travel ban that
affected a specific
group of citizens,
basically, with
certain restrictions
and limitations on movement.
Is that something that we
can relate to 14th Amendment?
Do people, visitors from
outside the United States,
are they considered, basically,
subjects to 14th Amendment?
ABDI SOLTANI: So being
Iranian-American and working
at the ACLU, the whole run up
in the presidential election
with the language of the Muslim
ban was quite alarming to me,
to other people
who are Muslim or
from Muslim-majority countries.
But I think it was
alarming to everyone
because our country has a
tradition of religious liberty
and religious freedom.
And the statements
of candidate Trump
were incredibly toxic in
terms of speaking those words
about making people of a
religion a suspect class
or a suspect group.
Already, his statements
as a candidate
had a horrible effect,
because they gave voice
and they legitimized the
idea that we can discriminate
based on religion.
Within days of
becoming president,
I think it's one of his
very first executive actions
was the first Muslim ban.
So in the design of our
system of government,
preceding the 14th Amendment
in the Bill of Rights
is also the Fifth Amendment.
The Fifth Amendment is the
same due process clause
that says that before a person
can have their life, liberty,
or property taken, there has
to be due process of law.
Due process means
that there has to be
a rational basis to the
decision of the government.
There has to be notice.
There has to be a hearing.
Usually, in the
criminal context,
that means there
has to be evidence,
that you have an
opportunity to respond
to the evidence, et cetera.
Due process is fundamental
to the rule of law,
and by extension, the equal
protection under the law.
So the 14th Amendment--
we don't usually
have to go to the
14th Amendment.
We can often go straight
to the Fifth Amendment,
where it deals with the
federal government itself.
And we also have the
nation's immigration laws
that are enacted by
statute that you can also
protect someone's rights.
So why was the Muslim
ban 1.0 so offensive
to our constitutional rights?
First of all, it was the
embodiment of the statements
that Donald Trump
had made that he
wants to ban the entry of
Muslims into the United States.
It was the way in which his
government officials could
give life to that promise.
It wasn't every Muslim
from every country.
They had to cabinet to
what his people thought
they could pull off.
What was also so
offensive about it
was that there are
people who were literally
on airplanes, people who had a
visa in their hand, people who
were landing on the
shores or in the airplanes
or airports of the United States
who were being denied entry
or who were being turned away.
More than that,
there are people who
are green card holders who are
being intimidated into giving
up their green cards.
None of that had any
due process of law.
What I love about the court
decisions of those days
is that it said
that even if you're
a person who has
not yet even set
foot on United States soil--
that you had gone to a
consulate in Dubai or in Turkey
and had gotten a
visa, and you're
in an airplane coming
to the United States--
you're still protected by the
Constitution of the United
States.
You might not be a citizen.
You might not be a legal
permanent resident.
But even as a visa
holder, you're
entitled to the due process and
equal protection of the law.
But what I was the most
inspired by at the time
of the first Muslim
ban was not just
that the ACLU
lawyers went to court
or that the judges made
the right decisions.
It was the way that the
American people responded.
In 1941, after the
attack on Pearl Harbor
and the executive order for
Japanese-American internment,
the ACLU here in the
Bay Area, the ACLU
of Northern California, we
represented Fred Korematsu
in a case that went to
the US Supreme Court.
At that time, the
number of people
who spoke up on the side
of Japanese-Americans
was extremely few.
But when the Muslim
ban was announced,
the American people responded
and rallied around--
not just the people who were
being detained at airports
or who were being turned away--
but they rallied
around the core values
of this country of
religious liberty,
of welcoming people to
our shore as immigrants,
and all of those
traditions that have
made us proud to be Americans.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE].
But if we want to go back to
the 14th Amendment itself,
are there areas that the
14th Amendment is under--
are there areas
where we can improve?
Where are the places where
14th Amendment is not
being completely followed
or observed that we
think we have to invest on?
ABDI SOLTANI: So the
reason, this year, I'm
speaking even more about the
14th Amendment is that this
is the 150th anniversary
of the ratification
of the 14th Amendment.
It was adopted in
1868, just a few years
after the end of the Civil War.
And over the course
of this 150 years
where we've had
the 14th Amendment,
it's remarkable to really
look at that history.
In the 10 years after
the abolition of slavery
is this period called
Reconstruction, in which
the United States made
incredible progress
in advancing the right
to vote, education,
economic opportunity for and
by the newly freed slaves.
The way in which the
African-American community
and their allies among many
other Americans-- including,
at the time, the radical
Republicans in Congress--
were able to seize that moment
and make very fast progress
is one of the most inspiring
periods in American history.
I would argue that the period
from the abolition of slavery,
that first decade--
more was done to advance
liberty than even
the first American Revolution.
To go from the
condition of slavery
to the gains of
the Reconstruction
is the farthest distance in
the advancement of liberty
in American history, full stop.
The period of the American
Revolution initially,
with the Constitution,
is remarkably important.
But the American Revolution
and the original Constitution
also strengthened the
institution and the law
on the side of slavery.
It was written into
the Constitution.
It took the Civil War and
the Reconstruction movement
to break down the
way in which slavery
was written into
our Constitution
and make those advances.
That period of 10 years of
Reconstruction's progress
came to a very
rapid halt and was
replaced by a very long
period of Jim Crow--
is the term for
legalized segregation.
That segregation included the
force and power of state laws,
of federal laws.
It also included
horribly unjust decisions
of the Supreme Court
of the United States
in a series of
decisions that took back
many of the gains of
the 14th Amendment.
It was also backed by violence--
through widespread violence,
fear and intimidation
against black people,
as well as whites
who were involved in
voter registration
or on the side of
equality, as well.
Although the magnitude
of the attack was most
pronounced against
African-Americans.
That period of Jim Crow,
or legalized segregation,
lasted for a very long
time until the Civil Rights
movement.
So I think we have to look
at the long arc of the United
States.
The American Revolution,
the original Constitution,
the Bill of Rights--
they are profoundly
important advances
for human liberty and
equality, the struggle
to abolish slavery, the
period of Reconstruction.
The movement to secure the
right to vote for women--
it's one of the longest
movements if you look
at the duration of time that
it took from the time that we
secured the 15th Amendment,
which protects the right
to vote regardless of race--
the 15th Amendment was one
of the three
post-slavery amendments--
that was adopted in 1870.
It took another 50
years, until 1920,
when the 19th Amendment
protected the right
to vote regardless of sex.
So I think we have to
take a bit of a long view
of American history.
We are in a period where a
lot of fundamental rights
are under attack.
We've been through that before.
And the only way we've
gotten through it
is by every person standing
up on the side of equality
and freedom and justice
and using their voice
for those enduring values.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much.
Now going back to the discussion
that we started on travel ban,
and later on, I guess,
family separation falls
into the same category,
we saw extreme support
from people who thought
that this is unjust.
This shouldn't be happening.
People are going to
airport, very heartwarming.
Although the family
separation issue is ongoing,
we just recently heard that
another 1,500 cases of kids
that were put under care,
as their cases are missing,
and they cannot be
tracked, and so on.
So that issue is ongoing.
But the point that
I want to get to
is that there was this
political atmosphere that
allowed these two rather
cruel acts to go into effect.
A few years ago, like,
probably, five, 10 years ago,
it would have been unimaginable,
things like this happening.
Like, singling out
Muslims, or separating
children from their families in
the way it happened and so on.
What happened in our
political atmosphere that
allowed for things like
this to actually happen
in the first place?
So what was the root cause,
and how can we prevent it?
How can we address the root
causes of this situation,
of anything like this
being even accepted?
ABDI SOLTANI: You know, I think
that there's maybe, like--
I'm going to simplify
this a little bit,
but maybe two
categories of people.
There's the category
of people who
after Trump won, woke up
and were kind of shocked
that this could happen.
You know, like, how
is it even possible
that a person who says
the things they do
could win the election?
And then there's
a second category
of people who've been actually
dealing with and facing
pretty deep-seated
discrimination in the United
States that has
had very deep roots
and for whom this was
actually the manifestation
of that exact existing
set of problems.
I think whichever
way one looks at it,
the current situation,
in terms of the policies
of this administration,
are at a different level
in terms of their
cruelty, in terms
of how patently they are
designed to carry out
a policy of exclusion.
Going back to the
14th Amendment,
of which I'm very fond--
you know the 14th Amendment
is a chain of words
that says all persons born
or naturalized in the United
States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are
citizens of the United States
and of the state wherein
they reside.
This sentence represents a
path from person to citizen.
And I think that we have
to be very clear eyed,
that the totality
of the policies
of the current administration
is to stop every possible point
in that path.
So it includes the
mass deportation
of undocumented immigrants
without due process.
It includes reducing
dramatically the number
of refugees that the
United States will
permit to come to the country.
A new policy that we have seen
through leaked news reports
is this idea of public charge.
Historically, the United
States would deny a path
to citizenship for a person
who was institutionalized
in the care of the government.
The idea was that you
have to be somewhat
self-sufficient to be able to
get through the immigration
process.
They now want to
change that definition
to include just
about anybody who
has received any form of
services from the government.
So that's another
attempt to limit
that path to legal immigration.
So I think that that's a major
cumulative set of policies
that's designed to keep the
United States demographically
from changing and its intended
purpose is to keep people out--
and very much from Latin
America, Central America,
Africa, Asia, et cetera.
The idea of family--
chain migration, which
they are also focusing on,
has been the main vehicle
through which Asian-Americans
have immigrated to
the United States.
There's really nobody who
is immune to these policies
of exclusion.
At the same time,
there's a set of policies
that are aimed at
the rules of the game
and the way in which power
itself is distributed.
So the attack on the right to
vote with the concerted efforts
at voter suppression, the
political gerrymandering
of districts so that it reduces
the influence of each voter
in their state or federal
government, the inclusion
of the question about
citizenship in the census
that has the intended
effect both of
intimidating people
from taking the census,
but also of creating the record
by which then the government
can allocate differentially
certain benefits by population
according to citizen,
instead of according
to the number of persons.
So this is all very serious.
And I think that we
have to be involved
in speaking up for basic
principles of equality,
fairness, and freedom.
So the 14th Amendment, you know,
how it itself plays into it
is very much at the center
of a lot of these debates.
The equal protection
of the law--
well, who does that apply to?
Those words, equal
protection of the law,
did not make it into
the Constitution
until the 14th Amendment.
Those are the words
based on which
we've made a lot of the gains
for lesbian and gay couples
to have equal access to
marriage or to other government
benefits.
So our view is that that
principle of equal protection
needs to be robust
and inclusive,
and it needs to be a force
to combat discrimination.
Other people can view equal
protection very narrowly
and try to limit
its application.
And so that's going
to be something
that gets fought in the Supreme
Court in the coming decades.
SPEAKER 1: So I
want to move to some
of the topics that are more
related to practical aspects
of ACLU's work.
So we've heard about People
Power, the grassroots efforts
that ACLU is instantiating
around the country.
Can you tell us a little
bit about People Power,
and what are the ambitions, what
are the goals and objectives--
where we are, and
how we can help.
ABDI SOLTANI: So I spoke before
about the 14th Amendment.
But I also want people to know
I'm a big fan of the First
Amendment.
And you can think about
the First Amendment
as something that's
a legal protection.
But it's actually an incredibly
beautiful and poetic.
And if you haven't
taken the time
to read the First
Amendment recently,
I'd really encourage you to.
It says that Congress
shall pass no law abridging
the freedom of religion
or to establish religion,
that Congress can pass no law
limiting the freedom of speech,
or the right of the people
to peaceably assemble,
or the right and the
freedom of the press.
And then the First
Amendment culminates in that
the government cannot
limit our right to petition
the government for a
redress of grievances.
So when you read the First
Amendment as a whole.
it begins from the place of our
inner beliefs and our values--
both the idea that the
government cannot tell you
your religion nor can
the government deny you
your religion.
And the case on
the First Amendment
has evolved to be clear
that religion includes
your conscience,
in many instances,
like your secular beliefs
that are deeply held.
And then from there, it goes
to your freedom of speech
and of the press and your
power to assemble as a group,
and then petition the government
for a redress of grievances.
So it's a chain
from your beliefs
to your relationship
to government.
And this is a very simple
point that I'm making.
There's a beautiful book written
called "Madison's Music."
It's about looking at
the First Amendment
as a holistic principle.
So to your question about People
Power, our view at the ACLU
is that the kinds of assaults
that we're facing on our rights
are not ones that we can
secure only through the courts.
They require the
participation of people
in the exercise of
their freedom of speech,
in their assembling
together peacefully,
and in petitioning
the government.
That is the First
Amendment itself.
So PeoplePower.org is
a new flank of the ACLU
that's an online platform
that allows people to organize
in defense of their liberties,
in defense of equality,
in association with the ACLU.
And for us, as a long
time legal organization,
this was a recognition
that, while we're
going to continue
to go to court,
the ultimate defense of
liberty is people's involvement
exercising their
First Amendment rights
through organized campaigns like
we offer on PeoplePower.org.
SPEAKER 1: Very well.
Thank you.
So you mentioned
First Amendment.
And I want to ask a question
that is a little bit related
to First Amendment.
So this is a discussion that
these days is being discussed
in the media to some extent.
Some people are worried
about giving platforms,
unintentionally giving
platform, to hateful speech.
But this is not the first
time that hateful speech
is appearing.
The incident of William
Shockley and Yale University
from the 70s, that's
a very famous one.
What happened afterwards,
there was this postmortem,
this discussion of what
are the boundaries, what
are the sort of speech that we
have to allow to take place.
And we know that the ACLU
has been on forefront
of defending First Amendment.
What are your advices?
What are your
thoughts or mindset
on how we should
set the boundary,
where should we draw the line
between speech that is not
going to be tolerated
and something
that has to be tolerated,
no matter what?
Where is the boundary?
What is a guideline?
ABDI SOLTANI: So this
is a great question,
and one that is the subject of
a great deal of legal thought,
social science thought, and
people's own conversations
about what is that line.
I think the basic
principle of the ACLU
is that we do not want to give
that power to the government
to decide who can say what
and when they can say it.
One of the earliest, and
one of the famous cases
that the ACLU brought here
in Northern California,
was the case in a poem called
"Howl" by Allen Ginsberg.
So if anyone goes to North Beach
neighborhood in San Francisco,
you'll come across
City Lights Bookstore.
And they were the publisher--
with Lawrence Ferlinghetti--
the publisher of Allen Ginsberg,
the poet of this beautiful
poem called "Howl."
The poem talks about gay sex.
It talks about drug use.
It talks about depression.
And those things were considered
offensive and obscene.
And for that reason,
that poem was censored,
I believe, by the postal service
that wouldn't distribute it.
So we went to court.
This is the 1950s.
And won a ruling on the side
that this poem can and should
be published and the government
cannot censor something
because someone
considers it obscene.
I think as time has
passed, a lot of people
have kind of lost track of that.
And there's a sense
that if there's
language that's
hateful, if there's
language that's discriminatory,
that we should give
the government the power,
in one form or another,
to limit the expression
of that view.
And the ACLU-- we still
stand by the principle
that that would be a really
dangerous path to go down.
It is dangerous for
a number of reasons.
One is that we don't believe
that force or government
power should be used to suppress
the ability of a human being
to express a point of view.
Beyond that, once you create
that basis and legal precedent,
or in other places, that
will be used in all manner
to restrict all forms of
expression that someone
finds offensive, or
discriminatory, or the like.
Now what are the limits to that?
One is the limit of
a threat of violence.
If there's a
statement that is made
that's targeted an individual,
and it's a threat of violence,
that's different.
Another would be, like, sexual
harassment or racial harassment
in the workplace or in a school,
where a person should have
the right to free
employment and education,
free from discrimination.
So there are places where
there's a limit to it.
You know, Google being
a technology company,
one of the big challenges
is on platforms like YouTube
or social media
platforms, which is
an inordinately complex area.
But we're mindful of
how do you make sure
that you don't hand that
power to large corporations
to then be the deciders
of what can be said
and what can't be said.
But some of this language does
cross the line into threats.
And so how do you manage that?
That's the problem that the
ACLU is concerned about and one
that I know companies
are also dealing with.
SPEAKER 1: So what are the
dangers of overreaction here?
So that's something that we
see on the progressive side,
people, like, being
really worried.
Are you yourself worried?
Is there any sort of advice
that we can make to people who--
may be studying about past?
Because this is
not the first time,
this isn't the first episode
of things like this happening.
ABDI SOLTANI: You
know, my advice
would be let's say there's a
speaker who has been invited
to come to a university.
And there's a group of
people who object strongly
to the points of view that that
person has expressed before.
It is equally a freedom of
speech of those protesters
to protest that
speaker's coming.
At the same time, you can
also just ignore the person
and not give them the
platform of the conflict
that they're also looking for.
But I would just
say that I don't
think it's wise to try
to shut down the speaker
and to use the protest for
the purpose of shutting down
the speaker.
I think that that goes
really into an area that's
not within the realm
of a free society.
And as satisfying
as that might be,
the way that that
plays out over time,
it does not lead to
a good destination.
Someone might say, well, giving
these people the platform
to speak will also not
lead to a good destination.
But I think we have
to be wise in how
do we make the choices
about how we protest,
how we exercise our
freedom of speech
to lead us down a path towards
actual freedom and actually
equality.
So when a person
is coming to speak,
and if you object to
what they have to say,
you can exercise your
freedom of speech vigorously,
and you can protest
it, and that, too,
is the freedom of speech.
But I would just
say where it crosses
a line is where we expect
government authorities to be
the ones to censor
someone or where
we use our protests in order
to shut other people down.
I think that's a line
that's not worth crossing--
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So--
ABDI SOLTANI: --or even
appropriate to cross.
SPEAKER 1: ACLU of
Northern California--
I want to talk about some
California-specific issues.
In particular,
criminal justice reform
is one of the areas of interest
that you have been, yourself,
very active in.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the activities
at Northern California
ACLU, taking on that regard?
ABDI SOLTANI: Yeah.
So you know, when
you get into reading
the Constitution and
especially the Bill of Rights,
the original 10
Amendments, a lot of it
is about the operation of
the criminal justice system.
The Fourth Amendment
is the right
to be secure in our persons
from unreasonable search
and seizure.
The Fifth Amendment is
a due process provision.
The Eighth Amendment protects
us from cruel and unusual
punishment.
So for an organization
whose mission
is to provide for and
protect constitutional rights
for everyone, the
criminal justice system
becomes, by definition, a
central part of the work
that the ACLU does
today and has done
for the better part of a
century of being in existence.
Beginning in the
1980s especially,
the set of policies in the war
on drugs and other policies
really led to this rapid growth
in our criminal justice system,
what we call mass incarceration.
And that period also marks
a very rapid increase
in the number of
people of color,
especially African-Americans,
as well as Latinos,
being part of that
system of incarceration.
In the arc of what
we were talking
about with the 14th
Amendment, there's
a wonderful book written by
Michelle Alexander called
"The New Jim Crow" that a
lot of people have read.
It's gotten a lot of attention.
And Michelle makes the
argument that the system
of mass incarceration became
the next manifestation
of the previous system
of racial segregation
that was created after the
period of Reconstruction.
And this became the
new, legalized way
in which to promote inequality
after the gains of the Civil
Rights movement.
So all of that to say that this
is an incredibly important area
of work.
Over the last eight or so years,
the California legislature,
California voters,
Governor Brown
have enacted a set of reforms
to reduce the number of people
incarcerated.
Initially, part of the
pressure was the recession.
There was pressure to
cut government, state,
and local government spending.
And incarceration is
a pretty unwise use
of resources, especially
the way we've been doing it.
But it was also prompted partly
by a Supreme Court decision
in a case called
Plata that dealt
with the condition of
incarceration in our state
prisons.
So right now, today,
there are a couple
of places where we
really urge people
to be attentive and involved.
The first is our
county prosecutors,
which in California are
called district attorneys,
they are the most important
actor in the criminal justice
system.
When you think about this
problem, 90%, plus or minus
of incarcerated people are
held either in local government
or state government.
This problem of
mass incarceration--
there are federal issues
that are involved,
but it's very much a
county and a state issue.
So every person should know
who is your elected district
attorney.
If you live in Santa Clara
County, San Mateo County,
or if you're watching
this anywhere else,
there is someone in
your county government
who is your representative,
the advocate of the people
in the criminal justice system.
And at the ACLU,
we're asking people
to know who that official is.
Call that office and ask
them to pursue policies
that reduce incarceration,
that promote alternatives
to incarceration.
So that's one major area.
And I mean, for the
people in the room,
raise your hand if you know
who your district attorney is
for your county.
So for the people
watching on the webcast,
there's a lot of shrugging
and very interesting
facial expressions that
all say we don't know.
So I would make that
your assignment today.
Look up who is your
county district attorney,
and make a phone call
to that office and say,
I am concerned about
the fact that I
live in a country
that is the world's
leader in incarceration.
And I'd like to know what are
the steps your office is taking
to dramatically reduce the
number of people who are locked
behind bars, to find
alternatives to incarceration
for people with mental
health problems,
or for people who can be
set on a different path.
And then centrally,
what steps are you
taking to address
racial inequality
in the decision of who to charge
and what charges to pursue?
I think for any of
us, whether we're
a citizen or a person
who's not a citizen,
to abrogate our voice in
our criminal justice system
and to not hold these people
who are elected accountable
is giving up part of
our responsibility.
Because they are carrying out
these policies in our name
as the elected representative
of the people in court.
So that's part of our
responsibility to check that
and to rein it in.
A second big area is bail.
And I think that that's a space
in which we are very active.
More than half of the people
who are held in our county jails
are people who are not yet
found guilty of a crime.
They've been charged
of a crime, and they're
being held awaiting trial.
In the United States, when
you are charged with a crime,
you have an opportunity
usually to post bail.
And the Constitution actually
says that there shall not
be excessive bail.
But when we live in
a time, in an era,
where there's so much
economic inequality,
most Americans cannot handle
like a $400 car emergency,
let alone have to pay tens of
thousands of dollars in bail
to await trial outside of jail.
So what you do is, you post a
bond through a commercial bail
bond company.
The commercial bail bond
industry, the way it works
is that, if your bail is, say,
$50,000, the $10,000 of it
is nonrefundable.
So even if you show up to
court, you don't get that back.
And so for a lot of people, that
then creates this cycle of debt
and contributes to poverty.
And so even if you're innocent,
even if you meet every court
date, you're still left
with that economic penalty.
So replacing bail
requires us to be
very thoughtful about
what do we replace
the system of
commercial bail with.
I don't think there's
much to be said in defense
of commercial money bail.
It's kind of hard to justify
the idea that a person who
has money can secure their
freedom through bail,
and a person who
doesn't languishes
in jail awaiting trial.
It's pretty hard to
defend that system.
I think we've done a good job
of making the case for why
we need to make the switch.
But I think that
the alternative is
one that needs to be very
carefully thought through
to be one that
reduces incarceration
while people await trial.
And we could talk about that
some more if you'd like.
AUDIENCE: Didn't the
city of San Francisco
just pass something that
eliminates the requirement
of bail, or the--
ABDI SOLTANI: Yes.
So it's a great question about
whether San Francisco voted
to end bail.
There's a movement around the
country to end commercial bail
and switch to a system where a
person can receive services, be
out of jail while
they're awaiting trial.
With rare exceptions,
if the person poses
like an imminent threat
to public safety.
A lot of local jurisdictions
are adopting reforms to bail.
There's another related
issue, which is around
fines and fees that are
charged to criminal defendants,
or people who've been in jail.
And jurisdictions like San
Francisco and Alameda County
are moving in the direction
of eliminating those.
But California has
not eliminated--
well, the legislature
just passed a bill, SB10,
that the ACLU originally
sponsored and supported.
But we ultimately withdrew
our support and opposed it.
What SB10 does is it ends
commercial cash bail.
But what it created
as an alternative
creates too much detention.
There's big categories
of people who
will be presumed to be
held in jail we just
felt that that is not the
direction that the bail
reform needs to go.
AUDIENCE: Data shows that school
segregation is getting worse
what do you consider as a
successful long term plan
to improve the integration?
ABDI SOLTANI: Wow,
great question.
That question is from
Anonymous-- good job,
Anonymous.
You know, the relationship
of school segregation
really also goes with housing
and residential segregation.
So when it comes to actual
segregation in terms
of schools, after
the Brown versus
Board of Education
decision in 1954,
which is as important a
Supreme Court as we have had,
what that said is that
we will not tolerate
separate and equal schools.
And there was a set
of policies that
went into place to create
integration and provide
more access to equal
educational opportunities.
Subsequent Supreme
Court decisions
said that that
responsibility does not
cross school districts.
It's only within a
given school district.
So to the extent that our
neighborhoods and our cities
are so segregated that people
cannot afford to live anywhere
in Santa Clara County or Alameda
County because of the cost
of housing or in the vicinity
of a school district,
it's very difficult under
current Supreme Court precedent
to create more diverse schools
across those school district
lines.
Within a school district,
school districts
can actually adopt
a number of policies
to make sure that the
schools are diverse.
And actually, the
ACLU has had a number
of cases here in California
that tried to do that
within the bounds of state law.
There's a Proposition 209, which
eliminated affirmative action
based on race or
gender, that also
has this negative
effect on the ability
to create diversity in schools.
But there's ways to do
it still within the law.
On education, though, there's
a whole set of other issues
that deal with access to
adequate funding for low income
kids and kids of color.
Also, one of the big issues we
deal with is the significant
racial inequality in school
suspensions and expulsions,
where the research shows that
for very similar behavior,
especially-- the most
extreme is black boys--
face very harsh
punishment compared
to other kids in the schools.
So those are a set of
issues around education
in which we're very active.
AUDIENCE: The preamble
to the First Amendment
says Congress shall pass
no law, dot, dot, dot.
And it seems that
there is a great deal
of misunderstanding in the
populace about that part of it.
Can you comment on the
legal ramifications
of, say, the social
media ban of Alex Jones?
ABDI SOLTANI: Yeah, so the
First Amendment, as you said,
does say Congress
shall pass no law.
And then it goes on
to fill that out.
So that has been understood to
mean that a mayor, a president,
a sheriff, a school principal--
that they can not
unconstitutionally
violate your freedom
of speech, as well.
So the Congress shall
pass no law is inclusive
of other actors in government.
And actually, it's
the 14th Amendment--
and part of why
it's so powerful--
is that it's the
14th Amendment that
took the rest of
the Bill of Rights
and applied it to local
and state government.
Until that time, something
like the First Amendment
didn't yet apply to
schools or to cities.
So the 14th Amendment sweeps
in the rest the Constitution
and applies it to
local government.
But the First Amendment
itself does not directly
regulate private conduct.
The First Amendment
doesn't limit my ability
to speak to you, and it
has limited applications
when it comes to private
companies or private platforms.
Even its reach in private
universities is limited.
So there is some ways in which
the First Amendment is limited.
But I think the principle
of freedom of expression
is one that we embrace and want
to apply in as many settings as
possible.
AUDIENCE: So next question
on the [INAUDIBLE]
is that what are
learnings and guidance
we can take from that
period of Reconstruction
to launch a movement for
equality and renewed commitment
to constitutional
rights for all?
How do we not repeat
elements of history?
ABDI SOLTANI: So thank
you for the question
about Reconstruction.
I think for anyone, if you
didn't hear the question,
it's what are the
lessons we can take
from the period
of Reconstruction
that we can apply today?
And also, how can we make
sure that we don't make
the same mistakes in the past?
There's some really incredible
books written on this subject.
In the last three years,
I've read more books
than I think I did
cumulatively in all of college.
Because I've been
really trying to learn
about this period
of American history,
which is full of
important lessons.
I would say the first and
foremost, the bedrock lesson,
is the importance of
protecting the right to vote,
but also exercising the right
to vote and running for office.
The period of Reconstruction,
in just a few short years,
there were thousands
of African-Americans
who ran for and were elected to
office throughout the country.
And I am actually
quite heartened to see
how much energy there
is right now in both
protecting voting rights,
but also encouraging people
to vote and people showing
more energy in that area.
But the great
warning of the period
of the end of
Reconstruction is the way
in which the courts can really
abandon their responsibility
when it comes to
equality and freedom.
And that's where it's so
incumbent on all of us
to-- you know, not all
of us can be a judge.
And so we have other branches
of government in which
we can exercise our power.
And for the people
who are involved
in the judicial system, it
is so important for them
to uphold the rule of law and
the principles of equality.
There's a set of
Supreme Court decisions
that very quickly came
one after the other.
The most famous is
Plessy versus Ferguson,
which allowed for explicit
racial discrimination to stand,
even though we had just
abolished slavery and passed
these incredible constitutional
amendments and statutes.
So I would just
say we have to just
be super alert, super active,
and do everything we can
in every facet of our lives.
And on that point,
what I would just say
is we have certain rights and
responsibilities as persons,
whether we're citizens or not.
We should use those.
We have certain rights and
responsibilities as citizens,
uniquely-- for example,
the right to vote.
We should use those.
We also have rights
and responsibilities
in our companies and
in our associations.
And so for people
who work in Google,
you know, your company
has incredible reach,
incredible power.
And as you're
looking at the future
of artificial intelligence,
or the applications
of your technology, there
are enormous consequences
for freedom, for
liberty, for equality
that you, as the stewards
of this technology,
are actually in
the best position
to see and address
at the source.
Ultimately, policymakers and the
public have to weigh in, too.
But I think you all
have a certain set
of responsibilities that I
would really encourage you to--
in many ways, you
already do exercise
with a great deal
of responsibility.
And I would really encourage
you to embrace that role
as being that guardian, right at
the source of the code itself,
or as the application or
the idea is being developed.
AUDIENCE: Question?
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering,
are there any active efforts
going on in ACLU to
fight the travel ban?
If yes, what, and if not, why?
ABDI SOLTANI: OK.
So the Supreme Court
upheld the Travel Ban 3.0.
And the Supreme Court's
say is the final say
when it comes to
the judicial system.
The way in which
we will continue
to fight the travel
ban, ultimately,
will be through
legislation in Congress.
Congress can change that.
A future president or a future
administration can revoke it,
can change it.
Ultimately, there will
also be other cases
that will go up to the courts.
So on July 5th, the ACLU
of Northern California
filed a case on behalf of an
Iranian-American family related
to how they were being treated
under the waiver provisions,
or under other provisions
that should be in place.
So the short answer to your
question is we will not rest,
and we will not give up, until
this policy of the Executive
Branch of the United
States government
is changed and replaced with
a system of immigration that's
not based on nationality,
or is not based on religion,
or other aspects of protected
human characteristics.
AUDIENCE: But there
are no active--
sort of direct
efforts, [INAUDIBLE]??
ABDI SOLTANI: There are.
Some of the groups we work with
have brought a class action
case on the waiver provision.
But there's not a new
path on litigation
after the Supreme Court
ruled on the issues
that the court already ruled on.
But I think that's where
the family separation
issue is so important.
That policy of separating
children from their parents
has many of the same
qualities as the travel ban.
It's incredibly cruel,
inhumane, and unjust.
It is motivated by the same
basic prejudice and principle
of trying to deny that
opportunity for people
to come to the United States.
And it also has all of
the same characteristics
of being completely
irresponsibly conceived
and executed, such that they
can't even find these children.
So we may need to move
our fight from one
arena to another arena.
But it's all still protecting
that same principle
of due process and equal
protection under the law.
And that's where I will
say, as an Iranian-American,
and as a person who has
earned his citizenship
because of something
like the 14th Amendment--
and to the question of
what are the lessons--
that's where we all have
to pool our resources
and pool our commitment
not just to protecting
our individual situation, but
protecting that basic principle
of equal protection under the
law, due process, and the rule
of law.
If those ideas are strong, they
can be strong for all of us.
But if those ideas become
weak, or if we abandon them
for one group, it
is the beginning
of abandoning it for everyone.
So the rights of women to birth
control, to contraception,
to abortion--
that is a fundamental
issue of equality.
The rights of lesbian
and gay couples
to love the person that they
love, the right of a person who
is transgender to live their
life free of discrimination
and to be able to live
their life safely--
these are issues
that we have to all
be in the circle of protecting
those freedoms and rights,
because we're all going
to be in it together.
I think if there's one
lesson from American history,
it's that.
It's that when we come
together in defense
of that basic set of commitments
and principles, all of us
do better, every one of us.
When that right starts to
be weakened or abandoned,
then it starts to take it away
from every single one of us.
So to your great question,
I would say we will persist.
And we'll find every
possible avenue
to address the issue
of the Muslim ban.
But the way we will all do
that is by working together
on the whole package.
AUDIENCE: In addition to the
important national issues
that you're working on,
what are the specific things
that Google can help to the
ACLU of Northern California?
How can Google as
a company help?
How can we as Googlers help?
ABDI SOLTANI: You know, I would
just encourage every Google
employee, whether you
work here in Mountain
View at the headquarters or
anywhere in the United States
or anywhere in the world,
to please be involved.
I would encourage you to have
a plan around the following
things.
One is your
charitable donations.
The ACLU appreciates
that support,
and we have many
other organizations
we work with that also
need that support.
So I think one is what do
you do in your charitable
giving as a person.
I think second is in
terms of your involvement
in your activism, in
voting, in being involved.
Whether you're a citizen or not,
you have the freedom of speech.
The right to vote
is the one part
that only a citizen can
do in the United States.
And then I would
encourage you as people
who work in one of the most
powerful and influential
companies in the world is to
develop products and services
that can facilitate
human communication,
human participation,
and to be really
watchful of those ways in which
your technologies can create
a backdoor towards
abusing people's rights.
And I think that's a place
where Google employees have
a disproportionate role
or influence in terms
of making sure that your
technology facilitates
human liberty and equality,
as compared to being a tool
that can be used for
those opposite purposes.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much.
Thank you for attending.
[APPLAUSE]
ABDI SOLTANI: Thank
you very much.